So today I'm going to be
talking about Shiny for Python.
Without a server running Python.
So Shiny for R has been
around for 10 years now.
It's kind of hard to
believe and if you
want to deploy one of
these applications,
you have to have a server.
Oops whoa.
Sorry this clicker is
a little sensitive.
You have to have
a server running
R, running Shiny.
Yesterday Joe announced
Shiny for Python.
And if you want to
deploy one of these apps,
you have to have a server
running Python, running Shiny.
But there's another option where
you can have a server that's
running nothing.
Now, before I go in depth
explaining what that means,
I want to tell a story about
the early days of Shiny.
So this was back in 2013.
Shiny had been around
for about a year.
And we had a server
that was available
where people could
deploy their applications
and people were putting all
sorts of interesting stuff
there because there's
scientists are using R and Shiny
and they're doing all sorts
of cool different things.
One of the applications
that showed up
was a quiz by somebody who was
a graduate student in statistics
at the time named Josh Katz.
So long time users of Shiny
are know what this is about.
This this is one
of the questions
that he had on the quiz.
So, what do you call the insect
that flies around in the summer
and has a rear section
that glows in the dark?
So you can say you could answer
this lightning bug, firefly,
I use them
interchangeably, or other.
So people would go to this,
they'd select their answer,
and it would display a map.
So in the green areas
here, this is where
people tend to say firefly.
The blue areas are where people
tend to say lightning bug
and the red areas are
where people use those two
words interchangeably.
All right, let's just
do one more for fun.
If I can get it to go.
How do you pronounce mayonnaise?
So with three syllables,
may-uh-naze, with two syllables,
man-naze, or
I use both interchangeably.
All right.
So here's the map
in red is where
people tend to say mayonnaise.
And in blue is where people
say mayonnaise and the green
is where people use
them interchangeably.
But there doesn't seem
to be a lot on this map.
All right.
So so you'd answer a
lot of these questions.
And at the end, it would
generate a map for you.
Sorry it would generate
a map for you showing
how similar your personal
dialect is to regional dialects
in the United States.
Now, this isn't my map, but this
is actually pretty close to me.
The red is where
your dialect is more
similar to the regional dialect.
So in this case, it's most
similar to Northern California,
and blue is where
it's least similar.
Now these maps were all
generated dynamically
and that was a little bit
computationally expensive.
So but when you're dealing with
four or five people, that's
not, you know, four or
five simultaneous users,
that's not a big deal.
But this got out
into some I believe
it got into some
linguistics blog
and then it got picked
up by the media.
This is Business Insider.
There was an article
that ended up here,
and my understanding
actually was
that this was the
most popular article
on their website that year.
So it got picked up here
and some other outlets.
And it ended up driving a
lot of traffic to our server.
So at some point we had
thousands of simultaneous users
and our server went
down and we had
to spin up new servers
in AWS to handle
all that computational load.
And this was back before we
had these automated scaling
and hosting systems
that we have now.
So that was a very
manual process,
ended up being very expensive.
We spent thousands of dollars
running all these servers,
but we survived.
But you know, this raises
an interesting question,
which is, wouldn't it be nice
if we didn't have to do all
that computation on the server?
So what are some ways of
not doing the computation
on the server?
One thing you can do
is maybe you can pre
compute the results.
So sometimes you can do this.
And sometimes you can't.
Nope sorry.
Clicker problems here.
Sometimes you can't.
So some of those maps could
have been pre generated
and actually Josh
changed his app to do that.
But that final one with your
personalized map could not be.
All right.
What about doing
computation on the client?
Well, you have a
couple of options here.
So one is to do the
computation in the web browser.
But if you know something
about web browsers,
that the only language they
understand is JavaScript.
So that's.
And so therefore you must
write your application.
Application in JavaScript.
And that can be a problem if
you're doing data science,
because a lot of the
tools that you're used to
might not exist in JavaScript.
So how about another option?
Send the code and
data to the client
and let the user run the
code on their computer.
So in order to do
this, though, you
need to duplicate your computing
environment on their computer.
And doing this, duplicating
your computing environment
is difficult and
it's a lot of work.
And you can't reasonably
expect somebody
to take that survey,
that fund survey
and have to install R and/or
Python and a whole bunch
of packages just to do that.
Well, this is actually the story
of how things were back then,
but things have changed.
So this part here
about web browsers
can only run JavaScript.
That's actually no longer true.
And the corollary is
also not true anymore.
So what other language do
web browsers support now?
Well, there's something called
WebAssembly or it's sometimes
abbreviated WASM.
This is a binary
format for programs
that can run in web browsers.
It's not a language that
you'd write by hand, normally.
Usually you'd write code
in C or C++ or some other
languages and compile it to
WebAssembly and then you can
run it in the browser
at near-native speeds.
So it turns out
Python is written in C
and there's actually a port of
Python called Pyodide which
compiles to WebAssembly and
can run in the web browser.
And of course, I have
to mention webR, which
is a project that
George Stagg started
and is working on, which is
R compiled to WebAssembly.
But this is still
in the early stages,
so I'm not going to talk more
about it in this presentation.
All right, so let's go
back to doing computation
on the client.
So this option 2 here,
this problem here,
duplicating a computing
environment is difficult.
Well, actually, if you compile
your computing environment
to WebAssembly, you can
send it to the web browser.
And it's actually becomes very
easy to duplicate the computing
environment.
So we'll cross that out.
And then we have this new
combination of options,
one and two.
So we send the code and data
and the computing environment
in WebAssembly to the
client and then run
all of that in the web browser.
All right.
So we have done this with Shiny.
So we've put together Shiny
and Python and WebAssembly
and we put it together
into something
that we are calling ShinyLive.
All right.
So I'm not going to tell
you more a whole lot
more about it right now.
I'm just going to show you
what you can do with it.
So how many people here have
gone to the documentation
website for Shiny for Python?
So if you did
that, that's great.
You might have seen
something like this.
So this web page
here and then there's
a running application there.
And I'll just show you
that it's actually running.
Well, this is just a video, but.
So this is a histogram.
You move a slider, and
it regenerates some data
and redraws the histogram.
So what you might not have
known is that you are already
using Shinylive.
These applications
on the website
are not hosted on a server
that's running Python.
These these examples
are all running inside
of the web browser.
So you can go and you can make
changes to this application.
We'll do it up here.
Let's just change this one.
So it generates a
uniform distribution.
So I'll take out
some of the UI stuff,
make some UI modifications.
Don't worry about the
details about this.
You just know that
you just have to know
that I'm changing some code.
And after we make
those changes, then you
can hit the Play
button and you can
see that now it's generating
uniform distribution.
So again, all of that, the
editor and this application
viewer panel in Shiny
itself, all of that
is running inside
of the web browser.
There's no server
running Python.
All right.
So what are some other fun
things you can do with this?
All right.
If you start on
the main web page.
And then there's
an examples button
you can click to see to
browse some examples.
There's this you don't have
to be able to really read it,
but on the sidebar, there's
some interesting examples there.
One of them is a simulation of
the moon orbiting the Earth.
All right.
And I'm just going to.
So what we have here is
the code editor and then
the running
application over there.
And again, this is all running
inside the web browser.
There's no there's no server
in the back running Python.
So you can make changes to the
initial speed of the Earth.
And then if you do that, you can
see how the moon will follow it
as it orbits.
But let's say I want to
make some changes to this.
This this app is a
little complicated.
I want to simplify a little bit.
So let's go ahead and
do that really fast.
So you can make these
changes right in the browser
and rerun the application and
try all sorts of new things
out.
All right.
So here we are.
We've simplified the
application a little bit.
I know it looks pretty similar,
but it is actually simpler.
And this is maybe we've
learned a lot about using Shiny
by doing this.
Now, you might want to share
this with people, right?
Normally to do that,
you would have to
deploy it to some server
that's running Shiny.
But there's another option
here with Shinylive,
and I'm going to
zoom in a little bit.
I know this still
may be hard to see,
but I'll show it
even closer later.
So there's a share button and
then when you click on that,
it'll provide these
two sharing links.
And one of the top
one says Editor URL
and you can copy that URL.
Send it to somebody
and when they paste it
in their web browser,
they'll open it up
and they will see the
application running
in their browser as well.
And they have that editor panel
and the running application.
So this is good
if the person you're sending
to is interested in the code
and looking at it
or modifying it.
But maybe the person is
not interested in that.
Maybe they just want to
see the application itself.
So there's another link,
the Application URL,
you can copy that
and send it to them.
And then if they put
that in their browser.
It'll open it up and it'll
be running that application
in the full window.
All right.
So you might be wondering, like,
hey, how much does this cost?
How do I sign up for this?
And the answer to
those questions
is, it doesn't cost
anything, and you
don't have to sign up
for anything to use this.
So let's take a
look at this URL.
This might help explain
things a little bit.
So this is what
the URL looks like.
So it's shinylive.io slash pi
slash editor and then code equals.
And then there's
this big string.
So that's actually
that string is actually
the whole application
code encoded into the URL.
And when you make a request,
when you send that to somebody
and they go visit that.
The web browser makes a request
just for this first part,
the part in blue.
So it requests Shinylive.
Hey, send me all the
Shinylive stuff,
the WebAssembly and
JavaScript stuff.
And Python stuff.
Of course it does not send
this part to the server.
That part is just
in their browser.
And so the browser
then takes Shiny
Live, decodes the
application, and then
runs it all inside the browser.
So that means that
the server is just
serving these files without
having to think about it.
It just sends out tons of files.
And that's really easy
for web servers to do.
Now, you might be
thinking, well,
sharing Shiny apps with
a URL that might be fun,
but maybe the app
and data is too big
to make a reasonably sized URL.
I mean, browsers can
actually handle from testing.
I found a really large
URLs these days like even
in the megabytes, but that's
that you don't typically
want to do send a huge URL
like that. Maybe it feels weird
just it feels weird to encode
a, an app in a giant URL. That
just seems strange.
Or maybe.
If I can get this
clicker to work,
maybe I don't want to depend
on the server at shinyapps
dot io.
Which I don't have
any control over.
Well, I have control over it.
But you don't.
So another option is to deploy
your Shinylive application.
So in order to do this,
there's two steps.
The first is to save your Shiny
live assets and application
files to a directory.
And then upload that directory
to a web hosting service
like GitHub Pages, or Netlify,
Amazon S3, or CloudFlare pages.
ß
00:14:07,160 --> 00:14:10,160
If you're old school, you
can use an Apache web server
or you can deploy it to RStudio
Connect, which is useful
because it provides
authentication and access
control if you don't want
the whole world to be
able to see the application.
And let me show
you how this works.
So it's pretty simple.
All right.
So, OK, let's say I have
my application files
in a directory called myapp.
Now then there's a
command line tool
that comes with Shiny
for Python called Shiny.
And you say Shiny static
myapp site.
So site is the directory
that we're writing it to
and it copies it downloads and
copies the Shinylive assets
and puts them in there.
And then it also copies the
application files and puts them
in there.
And so now we have
a directory, we'll
take a look here directory
called site and then
and then we can test,
Hey can actually
serve this site
directory and, and have
people run my application?
So we'll just run this
simple web server,
Python web server and
look at visit local host
and then it will load the
application right here.
All right.
Now, at this point, this is when
you can take that set of files
and just upload it to your
static web hosting service,
whatever that may be.
OK let's take a look at
the deployment model here.
So for a traditional
Shiny app deployment,
you have a server that's
running R or running Python.
And computers connect to it.
And when they
connect to it, they
maintain this open connection.
The user interacts
with it a little bit.
It sends data to the server, the
server does some computation,
and it sends some
information back.
For Shinylive app deployment
you have a server that
doesn't run R or Python.
When the user connects
to it, it sends
it sends Python
and the app code.
And Shiny, of course, to those
computers, and all of that stuff
runs inside of those
client computers.
And it's very easy for a server
to just send those files.
That's that's not a
computationally intensive thing
to do.
So it can serve you can serve
a lot of users this way.
OK let's talk about the
benefits of Shinylive.
To summarize, so the
entire application
runs on the client
instead of the server,
so there's no computational
load on the server.
It's really easy to
share these applications.
It's easy to deploy them to
a static web hosting service,
and it's easy to scale
them because that's
what these static web
hosting services do.
That's that's their
bread and butter.
And it's very cheap.
And it works on devices
without Python installed.
So like Chromebooks
or iPads or phones.
And this is not just for
viewing the application,
but you can even
edit the applications
and play with them on there.
So it's not
it's not all sunshine
and rainbows.
There's also a few
drawbacks and limitations.
So one is that not all packages
are available in Pyodide.
So Pyodide contains a lot
of packages in the Python
scientific stack, including
pandas and matplotlib, but not
all packages for Python.
You can install
packages from PyPi
if they're written
in pure Python
and don't have
any compiled code.
So but hopefully,
hopefully this situation
will improve in the future.
But that's what it is right now.
The code and data
for the application
is sent to the
web, web browser.
So there's no secrets.
Somebody can, in principle,
look at all the code and data
for your application if
they can see your app.
It's not good for
large amounts of data.
Like if you've got
100 megabytes of data
that your application
is operating on,
you probably don't want
to send that to somebody's
web browser, that's a lot.
It's not unheard of,
but that is a lot.
So the download side so download
size for a basic application,
the browser will download
about 13 megabytes of stuff.
And if you're loading packages
from there like, like pandas,
it's just going to
go up from there.
But fortunately browser
caching will speed up
subsequent visits.
So the first time somebody
views it, it might be slow.
And especially in
this conference,
Wi-Fi the first time
you visit one of these
may be a little bit slow,
but then in later visits
it should be
really, really fast.
And finally, the
browser security sandbox
restricts network connectivity.
But the good news is,
if Shinylive doesn't
work for your
application, you always
have the option to do
a traditional Shiny app
deployment.
You can learn this
one framework Shiny
and when it's appropriate,
deploy it with Shinylive.
And if that doesn't work
for you can deploy it
with a traditional deployment
just by learning one framework.
OK so this is where you
can learn more about it.
shiny.rstudio.com slash py
There's a link at the
top for Shinylive.
So also, it's.
It's still experimental.
Please keep that in mind.
We're still learning
a lot about it.
And so we can't wait
to see what you're
going to do with it, because
we want to learn what kinds
of possibilities people are,
what, what the possibilities
are, and hopefully you'll
be able to teach us that.
And of course, I know everyone
is thinking about this.
Yes we're hoping to do
this with Shiny for R.
Ah, but there's a
lot of work that
needs to be done before we
can get started on this.
Thank you.